my Lords and members of the House of
Commons my government's priority is to
secure the best possible deal as the
country leaves the European Union my
ministers are committed to working with
Parliament the devolved administration's
business and others to build the widest
possible consensus on the country's
future outside the European Union a bill
will be introduced to repeal the
European communities act and provide
certainty for individuals and businesses
this will be complemented by legislation
to ensure that the United Kingdom makes
a success of brexit establishing new
national policies on immigration
international sanctions nuclear
safeguards agriculture and fisheries my
government will seek to maintain a deep
and special partnership with the
European allies and to forge new trading
relationships across the globe new bills
on trade and customs will help to
implement an independent trade policy
and support will be given to help
British businesses export to markets
around the world my ministers will
strengthen the economy so that it
supports the creation of jobs and
generates the tax revenues needed to
invest in the National Health Service
schools and other public services my
government will continue to improve the
public finances while keeping taxes low
it will spread prosperity and
opportunity across the country through a
new modern industrial strategy my
government will work to attract
investment in infrastructure to support
economic growth legislation will be
introduced to ensure the United Kingdom
remains a world leader in new industries
including electric cars and commercial
satellites a new bill will also be
brought forward to deliver the next
phase of high-speed rail my government
will continue to work to ensure that
every child has the opportunity to
attend a good school and that all
schools are fairly funded my ministers
will work to ensure people have the
skills they need for the high skilled
high wage jobs of the future including
through a major reform of technical
education the national living wage will
be increased so that people who are on
the lowest pay benefit from the same
improvements in earnings as higher paid
workers my ministers will seek to
enhance rights and protections in the
modern workplace my government will make
further progress to tackle the gender
pay gap and discrimination against
people on the basis of their race faith
gender disability or sexual orientation
legislation will be brought forward to
protect the victims of domestic violence
and abuse my government will reform
mental health legislation and ensure
that mental health is prioritized in the
National Health Service in England
proposals will be brought forward the
ban unfair tenant fees promote fairness
and transparency in the housing market
and help ensure more homes are built my
ministers will work to improve social
care and will bring forward proposals
for consultation my government will
ensure fair remark 'it's
this will include bringing forward
measures to help tackle unfair practices
in the energy market to help reduce
energy bills a priority will be to
build a more united country
strengthening the social economic and
cultural bonds between England Northern
Ireland Scotland and Wales my government
will work in cooperation with the
devolved administration's and it will
work with all of the parties in Northern
Ireland to support the return of
devolved government a new law will
ensure that the United Kingdom retains
its world-class regime protecting
personal data and proposal for a new
digital charter will be brought forward
to ensure that the United Kingdom is the
safest place to be online legislation
will also be introduced to modernize the
court system and help reduce motor
insurance premiums my government will
initiate a full public inquiry into the
tragic fire at Granville Tower to
ascertain the causes and ensure that the
appropriate lessons are learned to
support victims my government will take
forward measures to introduce an
independent Public Advocate who will act
for bereaved families after a public
disaster and support them public inquest
my ministers will continue to invest in
our gallant armed forces meeting the
nature commitment to spend at least 2%
of national income on defence and
delivering on the Armed Forces covenant
across the United Kingdom my government
will bring forward proposals to ensure
that critical national infrastructure is
protected to safeguard national security
a commission for countering extremism
will be established to support the
government in stamping out extremist
ideology in all its forms both across
society and on the Internet so it is
deep denied a safe space to spread
in the light of the terrorist attacks in
Manchester and London my governments
counterterrorism strategy will be
reviewed to ensure that the police and
security services have all the powers
they need and that the length of
custodial sentences for terrorism
related offenses are sufficient to keep
the population safe my ministers will
ensure that the United Kingdom's leading
role on the world stage is maintained
and enhanced as it leaves the European
Union as a permanent member of the
United Nations Security Council
committed to spending 0.7 percent of
national income on international
development my government will continue
to drive international efforts that
increase global security and project
British values around the world my
government will work to find sustainable
political solutions to conflicts across
the Middle East it will work to tackle
the threat of terrorism at source by
continuing the United Kingdom's leading
role in international military action to
destroy daesh in iraq and syria it will
also lead efforts to reform the
international system to improve the
United Kingdom's ability to tackle mass
migration alleviate on poverty and end
modern slavery my government will
continue to support international action
against climate change including the
implementation of the Paris agreement
Prince Philippe and I look forward to
welcoming their Majesties King Philippe
II and Queen Letizia of Spain on a state
visit in July my government will host
the Commonwealth summit in April of next
year to cement its relevance to this and
few
generations members of the House of
Commons estimates for the public
services will be laid before you my
Lords and members of the House of
Commons other measures will be laid
before you I pray that the blessing of
Almighty God may rest upon your counsels